la situación en la ciudad de bacmut se
ha vuelto cada vez más insostenible es
una población en el centro del Don vast
que viene siendo asediada y atacada por
las tropas de Moscú desde el verano pero
la medida que pasan las meses y las
semanas la situación se ha vuelto peor Y
esto Incluso en los últimos días ya
solamente hay una vía de acceso desde
aquí desde la población de chasis ya que
está solamente a 10 km de distancia y
donde la guerra se siente como estaba en
backmud Hace algunos meses aquí nos
cuentan los pobladores que son atacados
constantemente se siente la entrada de
artillería y también se siente la salida
y las pocas tropas que todavía pueden
entrar a bakmuth lo hacen desde aquí en
los últimos días especialmente desde el
fin de semana se ha ido prohibiendo el
acceso a los periodistas
las brigadas militares que están allí
evitan acceder hasta allí cuenta los
pocos voluntarios los mínimos
voluntarios que piensan llegar que la
ruta es constantemente atacada que hay
pedazos de metal en la carretera que
daña las llantas y esto impide que se
lleve más ayuda humanitaria Para apoyar
a Esas cinco mil seis mil personas que
han decidido quedarse en bacmut lo que
hace que la situación sea aún más
crítica cuando se les pregunta a ellos
qué va a pasar realmente dicen que la
situación cambia Ora por hora algunos
dicen que algunos se retiran otros dicen
que siguen luchando en el centro de la
ciudad pero también lo que nos cuentan
es que los rusos van destruyendo las
edificaciones y van dejando a esta
población por el piso los temores son
aún mayores aquí en chasis ya porque la
población piensa que el mismo destino
que tuvieron la gente de bacmut lo vayan
a tener ellos en un futuro están
bastante cerca ven como el frente se
acerca y además dicen que realmente aquí
la situación es la misma que se vivía en
backmudas hace unos tres o cuatro meses
Así que esta es la situación en este
frente del donbas uno tal vez el más
activo y donde están los ojos de Ucrania
en este momento